in the jungles of Central Africa only
man for religion called Tweety believe
they have found a way to talk to the
dead
[Music]
the menti rituals are designed to send
followers into extreme altered states
the states that we t believe will
provide valuable spiritual guidance
at the heart of wheaty is a small shrub
which grows deep in the tropical jungles
it is called iboga and it's a cocktail
of some of the most powerful
hallucinogenic compounds known to man
in West African village two people
desperate to change their lives are
submitting themselves to a dangerous
mind-altering ritual
there is a notion that one has to get to
a point of bouncing back Don German is
an anthropologist at Smith College you
get sick almost to the point of dying
almost to the point of not being able to
survive this is a classic kind of rite
of passage
[Music]
after only his second dose Franck reacts
violently
[Music]
throwing up is normal in the booty
ceremony that might terrify an outsider
but to one thing it is just the Evoque
of working to rid Frank of his
deep-seated troubles their cuts to
bluffs
that's just his problems being released
on the inside unlike Frank bond bond
still appears unaffected by the Ebola
but she is refusing another dose to her
sweet tooth and Bolger is too bitter to
swallow
Frank is still vomiting blood but he is
now ready to let the whole
taken into another world a mirror is
placed in front of him
drops
bring on visions are put into his eyes
he stares into the mirror intently for
powers slowly losing contact with his
surroundings
how the bulgar causes hallucinations is
not fully understood it is believed that
iboga acts on the brainstem causing
blood and excite cells in the cerebellum
the cerebellum is the part of the brain
where motor coordination for memory and
dreams become together these
hallucinogenic effects and last for well
over 30 hours no bond pun tried to
refuse the iboga ultimately she is made
to down six doses of the water and
saying look look there's a small photo
it keeps changing it's becoming like a
small dog
now it's a mask it's changing bases
start slippin into another reality as
well
I saw my father he was pushing me with
snakes I can feel my heartbeat beat here
in my chest I could not wake up I wanted
to escape but my father's what
let her help terrified the visions
there's no turning back the initiatives
we'll have to ride it out
[Music]
[Applause]
emerging from their experience the
following day Frank and bonbon celebrate
their rebirth according to weighty
belief iboga enabled them to journey to
the ancestors and the gods and return
purified into a new life will it work on
bond and Frank seemed convinced that it
will
since I saw my mother it will change my
life like before I was not all here now
I am here I will look for a job I am
very happy the entities told me the
course of action to take they told me
make music that goes everywhere make
Universal music they said don't let the
past discourage you have confidence in
yourself and I'm sure that in the long
run things will get better better than
they were before
[Music]